siamo oggi su paper io due hanno fatto i
due dive perché c'era l'uno che vincevo
sempre io allora facciamo 2 almeno linfa
vj non ci vince le partite possiamo
goderci gioco vi sbagliate amici periodo
e le slot l'hanno fatto solo ed
esclusivamente per telefono quindi
giocherò sul telefono sono contento di
questo caso di questa cosa qua perché
almeno posso di mostrarvi la mia
superiorità in tutto e per tutto il nome
giusto è ricco pentolaio let's rock e in
inglese harry potter
vai non ho mai ricco pentolaio la cosa
che ho visto che è diversa dai soliti
paper io è che stavolta le cose che
create non sono quadrate ma ci puoi fare
il giro così già uno è morto cavalcavia
così fregato tu puoi fare il giro come
vuoi quindi tutti poi poi conquistare il
100 per cento la zona come in peperino
normale
solo che non è squadrata la faccenda è
un po come un minecraft non quadrato
perché vediamo se riesco bene
sono già due killah mi ha ucciso un bel
liber allora let's go riproviamoci un
tasto continua ho fatto schifo ma so che
posso fare di meglio
ricoh pentolaio può poi è bello che la
mia supremazia in giochi online sempre
dettata dal fatto che ho dei nomi che
fanno schifo perché scelgo sempre non
mila cani e la gente si distrae per
questo grazie mille nella pubblicità che
mi stai mettendo di sotto 2 kg già fatte
anche se ho fatto un pò schifo alla
prima partita non è male sembra fatto
molto meglio di pepe rio non ci credo mi
ha mangiato tutto porca vacca sono molto
più forti quelli visto gioco pipe per io
rispetto ha giocato ripe periodo dai è
difficilissimo è fatto molto meglio cioè
mi mi diverte molto di più è morto
quello grosso è morto pro lui mi diverte
molto di più del paper io normale solo
che mi sembra molto più dice lo so
perché la gente più forte sul telefono
ho capito bene sarà chiesto un maestro
della tastiera la gente anche stevie
wonder o maestro la tastiera che anche
mozart era un maestro alla tastiera
andato pure lei kill the thing
ma io a the king sori non sapevo neanche
legge
porco demonio chi mi fa fuori 3,16 sono
molto più scarso cuoche nell'altro
perché dai dai che palle il problema è
difficilissimo lo giuro ma scusami in
attivo ma se io arrivo che quando sei
squadrato e facile fare 100 perciò è
facile più o meno cene seconda di via
alla fine è facile concludere qua come
fai che si tutto storto e carino è per
l'amor di dio però non è e non è quello
che mi aspettavo cioè molto difficile
eccolo qua un piede disegna puoi
disegnare le cose praticamente
fortunatamente non c'è chi disegna penn
i ragazzi siamo i talking per un attimo
se uno si in tre lo stare attento a non
farvi fregare i punti minchia colore
gigantesco porca vacca della qualità in
sti giocatore che fa paura ma io fui più
qualitativo ciao detto è rimasto solo il
verde fatto fuori quello in teoria
dovrei tenere la testa sempre
sarei curioso di vedere dall'alto cosa
si vede nelle mie sculture quella il
bordo della mappa per caso voglio vedere
cosa succede quando vinci cioè come fai
a conquistare tutto quanto impossibile
cento in viola
basta porco demonio morto perché ok ho
già fatto fuori uno enorme sono xi dai
ero primo ragazzo farò mai a vincere
mi sembra una pigna cosa ho disegnato
sembrati qualcosa che ti fa lo psicologo
cosa vedi in questa forma non lo so poi
è bello che mentre passi dentro il
territorio di un altro lo scava proprio
cioè si avrebbe con animazione che scava
volevi porca vacca scoop i did fatto
fuori
incredibile mi sono salvato all'ultimo
secondo perfetto no perfetto ho fatto
mille kill dopo invece uno che si
chiamava mamma no tra i non ci credo per
niente ma se sarai scemo
bye bye bye zio mezzo veloce però ci
veloce veloce veloce non è vero non è
vero ragazzi no e mi sono impegnato
tantissimo
quello che skin aveva ma dai basta
fatemi giocare un attimo ok la partenza
è buona la partenza è buona il mio
colore lo è un po meno ma va bene ok ho
disegnato una papera molto bene sono
bravi faccio un miliardo di chili ma
perdo e non so perché basta prima che
distrugga il mio telefono faccio lui
l'ultima l'ultima ve lo giuro è l'ultima
non ne faccio più dopo questa giuro a
quello il bordo della mappa buona
sapersi arca vacca signori basta mi sono
roba basta bulbi mi voglio uccidere
fatevi fare solo una partita per
riprendermi al mio aldo vedove vincol
qualsiasi cosa nel mondo perfetto fa dj
così ma classi games
fatemi fare una solo qua giusto per per
mettere insieme parlare bisogna mettere
sulla mia supremazia e basta poi me ne
frega niente
uno è già morto un nuovo già fatto fuori
almeno qua qua non so perché sono
squadrato e lo fa e vinco sarà che le
forme mi confondono
l'idea però vabbè doveva i fratelli
perfetto sono dato prima in una botta
sola ero ultimo molto bene
e stato proprio bello io sono fortissimo
qua perché non lo sono anche nell'altro
perché guarda che stacco dato gli altri
c'era solo il valentino rossi di pepe
rio il primo ciak si è ammazzato da solo
ha visto quanto ero grosso ha detto
vabbè dai basta
bravo ciak così questa è la filosofia
giusta è messo innamorato di una
software camucia ciao ciao fratelli è
stato che vieni croazia
credevo di essere più vicino un
deficiente credevo di essere molto più
vicino un troglodita dai mela merito ma
questa mela america sono stato stupido
come la morte come fa essere prima uno
che si chiama armando ex alpage
spaghetti
beh non avevo dubbi ci sono riuscito a
perdere con un pirla ciò india india
india india t series è morta t series
armando è tornato sconfitto che bello è
morto è morto quindi niente adesso siamo
io contro armando vieni armando poi da
consorte bravo armando fortissimo
complimenti se parlo io ho fatto una
figura barbina prima ciao thomas del
quarto perfetto ma sono rivelare uno
primo perfetto vediamo di non fare
cagate come mio solito caro line cioè la
texture di minecraft cambiamo il gioco
l'unica persona ad uccidere fa vj e fa
vj tv chuck norris può ammazzare solo se
stesso fa vj va bene e la prima volta
che mi chiamo fa vige in giochi del
genere tra l'altro non mi sono mai
chiamato fa vj però proviamo a vedere se
l'iter io se faccio schifo the dumb 8
che non ci gioco solo per vedere come
funziona la faccenda qua se veramente è
un periodo in cui vado faccio schifo e
tutti i giochi io appunto pare sì vabbè
ragazzi proviamo riusare la mia tattica
che è quella di è che quella di stare
vicino a un gigante tipo questo qua per
vedere se riesco a far fuori la gente
non ti frega davvero stiamo gira ai
giganti tipo questo che lo stiamo per
uccidere se stiamo vicino ai giganti c'è
la possibilità che se che esplodano
io mi prende a tutti i loro punti quindi
la mia tattica è sempre stata questa
sera sempre vicini grossi poi quali
schiattano se hanno voglia
volevi sono i miei punti grazie
gentilissimo allora se mischiata pur
l'altro bene l'ho fatto io sono
fortissimo oggi non ne possiamo
concludere poi video per cortesia bella
ragazzi ma va bene dai facciamo l'ultimo
tentativo visto che ci sono in vena di
slip di giochi punto io solo per questo
motivo se non ho palco demonio ok la
cavo c'ero quasi un questo gigante
questo potrebbe morire attenzione anzi
ce ne sono due addirittura sesto se
neymar costretti c'è la possibilità
doppia che qualcuno muoia
non so dove dividermi quale dei due
schiatta secondo e l'arancione schiatta
ci ha dato persona ragione mi fido di
più del suo non saper giocare o anche
nel mio non saper giocare il modello di
strizzare le meningi ragazzi basta prima
che distro questa allora questa tastiera
qua non è un placement a me ne frega
niente non la fanno più quindi se io
tiro ancora un pugno stasera e la rompo
ho finito di fare video finita smettiamo
oggi no oggi non so fare una sega
oggi non so fare una sega una volta ero
bravo nel suo show schifo ragazzi basta
ho provato più evoluto che l'abito il
tavolo giocato a paper io per provare un
attimo la mia supremazia sono fortissimo
provato solite rio è questo gioco deve
bruciare quindi gran giornata produttiva
ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto ho
fatto un mix di dio
qualsiasi cosa appunto io oggi va bè
cosa vedo che ci sono demoralizzato uno
schifo prova bene
iscrivetevi e magari migliori anzi forse
non lo faccio più che è meglio sarebbe
anche meglio da ragazzi
[Musica]